mesdames et messieurs bonsoir après
l'île de la réunion le premier ministre
a visité aujourd'hui mayotte avant de se
rendre ce soir aux comores à mayotte qui
recevait pour la première fois un chef
de gouvernement d'un métropole monsieur
chirac a dit aux habitants qu'ils
resteront français au style longtemps
qu'il le souhaite
jean-louis le scène et notre envoyé
spécial que le premier ministre ait
passé plus de six heures en avion
militaire pour se rendre et à mayotte et
aux comores en dit long sur la volonté
de jacques chirac se régler un problème
qui s'éternise mayotte collectivité
territoriale française de 60000
habitants souhaite depuis longtemps
intégré davantage encore la communauté
nationale en devenant département à part
entière soit a affirmé le premier
ministre aux mahorais mais pas comme ça
et surtout pas toutes chaudes paysans de
chez moi
fillon qu'on coûte sagesse thèse il ne
faut jamais mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs je suis persuadé que cette
formule est vrai en toutes circonstances
et pour vous aussi et que vous
découvriez rapidement les inconvénients
qu'il y aurait pour vous même à poser
des principes avant de créer les
conditions pratiques de leur bonne
application et jacques chirac déterminé
de fustiger ceux qui veulent empêcher un
peuple à disposer de lui même
justement dans l'après midi c'est aux
comores république islamique
indépendante qui revendique la
souveraineté sur mayotte que le premier
ministre rend des visites passées les
nomment entre eux clore le cieux chirac
s'est montré conciliant pour renforcer
la coopération et ferme sur madoff
seulement si son hôte ahmed abdallah n'a
pas en public prononcé une seule fois le
nom de mayotte
jacques chirac lui n'a pas parlé une
seule fois de sa départementalisation
certains diront sans doute que les deux
hommes ont utilisé la langue de bois
d'autres qu'ils ont fait preuve d'une
rare diplomatie et pourtant à moroni
les slogans d'accueil était loin d'être
tout à fait innocente